okay ready guys  audition them there's a lot of pressure  here  my name is nick borrelli and i'm  traveling the country to sit down with  some of the biggest latinx artists in  places that are meaning to them and help  tell their stories it brings a sense of  emotion because you're standing there  looking at kids and go my god these kids  are are so communicative and they all  have their stories  there was nothing natural about me  playing baseball there was nothing  natural about me being a rock and roll  singer there was nothing natural about  me being an actor  naturally just using years of hard work  make you a natural  you've been a strong advocate for  representation for a long time trying to  understand your culture and  the roots that make you the tree that  you are or the human being that you are  makes everybody stronger  success is having lived your life doing  what you really wanted to do the  strongest advice i can give is don't  stop you know just don't stop  you